bonjour et laqué rieff merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous ce matin sur
la france on le voit derrière vous il ya
une mobilisation parce que il y a
quelqu'un de de l'ehpad de l'ehpad qui
est situé à marseille qui vient d'être
remercié par la direction c'est bien
cela alors c'est pas tout à fait ça j'ai
déménagé dans le gard parce que suite à
man lancement d' alerte sur le canal des
ehpad j'ai été blacklisté comme vous
avez pu le comprendre et le suivre sur
plusieurs chaînes de télévision
aujourd'hui j'ai atterri dans le gard et
je travaille pour un grand groupe privé
le groupe l sane la lie la clinique
bonnefon à aller c'est effectivement en
grève aujourd'hui l'ensemble des
salariés en a ras le bol
parce qu'aujourd'hui on dénonce une
pression économique une pression sur les
salariés on
muselle on n'est pas bonne ils ont plus
droit la charge qu'il est sous la menace
et même qu'on leur enlève leur emploi on
les licencie on les sanctionne des mises
à pied ont été
reçus par certains salariés des
avertissements etc deviennent
catastrophiques le climat au pré
enseignes les établissements privés
lucratifs
c'est juste inadmissible et la santé ne
doit pas faire partie du privé et du
coup je m'imagine que les révélations
faites hier par ce journaliste notamment
dans un grand ehpad parisien vous vous
conforte en tout cas dans votre combat
eh bien ça me donne encore plus
l'histoire et je me dis que le combat
continue et on va finir par se faire
entendre
on finit par se faire entendre par tous
de notre gouvernement qui jusqu'à
présent n'a jamais rien fait pour
soutenir nos aînés dans ses structures
pour soutenir tous les français qui
sommes dans l'obligation de mettre leurs
parents dans une structure qu'ils pour
qui l'heure de l'objectif et le rend
demain et je me dis que vers on y arrive
on y arrive à cet objectif et grâce à
lui grâce à toutes celles qui donnent la
parole tous les soignants toutes les
familles tous les résidents sont
maltraités aujourd'hui en france on va
finir par faire quelque chose et
j'espère vraiment que monsieur mac
rendent maintenant qu'il est un poireau
gouvernement va agir et va mettre une
pression forte et une sanction du cycle
hier à
exemplaire pour toute la france et tous
les français alors sais pas si vous avez
entendu justement le patron d'orpea il a
dit hier qu'il n'y avait pas de
maltraitance généralisée dans c est
parce que c'était le fait d'individus
parfois et que c'était finalement une
main qu'est ce que vous en pensez
alors oui c'est monsieur le directeur du
rhdp à ce message vous est adressée
directement un individu je veux bien
mais quand vous avez des millions de
familles des millions de résidents des
millions de soignants qui répète la même
chose dans toutes les écoles de privée
en france à but lucratif je pense que
c'est pas juste une voix isolée que
c'est une colère et une réalité c'est ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui dans les ehpad
privé lucratif la maltraitance est
institutionnalisée pardon et il faut que
ça cesse parce que il faut être honnête
parce que la maltraitance passe par les
les réductions drastiques de budget on
l'a vu et l'aide apportée à ces
personnes exactement quand vous devez
rationner un plat pour un résident qui a
travaillé toute sa vie qui paye 8000
euros une chambre par mois je trouve ça
scandaleux
quand on ne veut pas lui changer sa
couche plus de trois fois par jour
c'est de l'aberration on ne peut pas
continuer comme ça ça suffit c'est de la
maltraitance c'est des humains et des
humains qui veulent finir leur vie
tranquille eu marre et sereinement que
quel est l'état d'esprit du personnel
soignant dans les ehpad lorsque il ya
cessé rationnement
et b on est méprisé danesi pas de les
soignants mais ils n'ont pas le choix
que pour continuer de faire un d'exercer
et de gagner
de l'argent pour pouvoir nourrir leurs
familles et ils continuent à travailler
mais c'est pour ça aujourd'hui qui a
énormément de burnout énormément de gens
et de soignants qui quittent leur
métier qu'ils ont choisi par vocation
parce qu'ils n'en peuvent plus et parce
que leur petite voix à travers leurs
établissements mais elle n'est pas
portée au delà de au delà du combat et
de
vous expliquer ça
et de la force de ce combat l'importance
de ce combat les personnels soignants
devraient être mieux considérer mieux
rémunérés également
les personnels soignants doivent être
mieux considérer fait humain est
beaucoup mieux rémunérés quand
aujourd'hui vous avez un salaire net qui
a pau qui a provisoire ce qui est à peu
près à 1200 1300 euros pour douze heures
de travail tous les jours
avec une charge de travail aux
énormes on constate même et on a pu le
constater par le passé et on le constate
toujours que les accidents de travail
que ressasser ça dans le milieu du
soleil et que pensez vous alors il ya de
l'argent puisque les les sociétés
privées en tout cas font des bénéfices
on avait vu alors l'ordre but lors du
premier confinement des bénéfices
redistribués aux actionnaires qu'est ce
que ça vous inspire
mais on commercialise de notre santé
madame voilà ce que ça m'inspire c'est
comme pour monsieur commercialise de
notre santé notre avenir notre retraite
et que ses actionnaires via ils
devraient tous les matins l'argent me
regarde et l'argent qui donne sur leur
compte c'est la sueur et la maltraitance
et déjà qu'on attaque pour qui le
dernier se fixe et ça c'est inadmissible
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire qu'est ce
que vous demandez au gouvernement at il
les moyens d'agir au niveau des groupes
privés
bien sûr qu'il a le moyen d'agir parce
que le gouvernement distribue des
dividendes c'est à ces entreprises il
est leur donne de l'argent pour qu'ils
puissent exercer alors on va leur
demander si ça reste de donner de
l'argent aux établissements privés mais
qu'ils amènent plus au public et pour
que le public et s'agrandissent et qu'on
arrête de bannir la santé mary sont
bannis c'est plutôt la chanteuse privé
pendant
davantage d'établissements publics c'est
ce que vous réclamez donc c'est ce qu'on
réclame et de contrôle merci beaucoup et
merci et la carrière d'avoir répondu ce
matin prix en direct à nos questions sur
rt france